I'm gonna prove how good I am I'm gonna
prove that math is a science do you know
the history of pretzel study I mean
they're pretty good at making stuff up
I never made up a damn thing in these
things things I know you do all right
lay it on us pretzels what are they
twirly twirly birds to you grab with
your hands and you wrap them around
where did they come from
where did they go back in 1987 a young
man named Jordan beep written walked
into a kitchen and he said hey I'd like
to make myself a little bit of a snack
so he grabbed some flour he grabbed some
yeast he grabbed some salt maybe a
little bit of pepper then he went to
work pulled up his sleeves and he washed
his hands as you always do before
cooking a great meal and he spun ball
mixing vigorously until out of the oven
came something brand new something his
eyes had never seen before something
that would take the nineties by storm
the pretzel had been made and today
that's what we're doing we're taking
Jordan be Britain's original recipe and
we're honoring it and then serving it up
to him in his memory i I didn't I didn't
really agree with the idea of letting
Ethan do an intro I thought like I could
give him a chance to really prove
himself and he really let me down on
that one that was awful I've never let
anyone else do an intro for my channel
before ever and as the first video to
ever be introduced by someone else
I feel like this just like really sat on
the dream of markiplier makes the whole
but you know I'm not gonna let him know
that you know I always carry a smile on
cuz I'm always very much I'm about
always smiling that's my new initiative
hashtag always be smiling abs always be
smiling so I'm gonna take that take that
idea into the into the future yeah
there's gonna be a lawsuit against mark
for trying to take my hashtag but that
pretty much all I needed a preheated the
water's boiling so we have all the
ingredients that you need to make a
pretzel you've got flour
you've got confectionery sugar we've got
non-brand oil we've got store-brand
butter
you've got store-brand butter old metal
Wow so we combine these ingredients with
yeast and then you you fold it into a
pretzel shape alright so there are a few
complicated steps but as is usual with
marklar makes we do not have a recipe we
never have had a recipe we don't need it
we don't need a recipe because we are
cooking innovators not masters works
pleura tours you think that Lewis and
Clark were masters of exploring shut you
think that Lewis and Clark were masters
of exploration before they set out on
the Oregon Trail like they didn't know
what the hell they were doing they
didn't know where the hell they were
going and yet they still found something
the Louise in they thought yeah
Louisiana Purchase they were exploring
the new territory for the Louisiana for
that wasn't it that was them they were
it was and they found all of Louisiana
it found it all they found all of it
which back in the don't start oh my god
alright whatever we're starting okay
right so it's flour water salt water oil
and a little bit of sugar and the most
in Greece which I don't think you at
first I think you do because you have to
let the yeast rise right yeah are you
done yeah measuring is for [ __ ]
I am a penis I've made principal so many
times in my life I'm like a master I'm
gonna crush these guys in the
competition now I feel like I really
started this whole thing because they
didn't want to start that yeah they were
just blabbering on and I got ahead of it
I got ahead of them I put that yeast in
and I put that flour in that sugar all
of it and I'm ready to do Jordan you
know
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know what it's supposed to look
like but mine's looking better than
Ethan's all right let me show you some
some of my grandpappy taught me ah
joke's on you never met my grandpa no
I've got a nice it's a little sloppy but
here's something that others don't know
[Laughter]
thinks he knows something that we don't
I mean I mean I bet he knows a lot of
things that we don't I mean that every
person has individual subsets of
knowledge well I was talking more than
bacon and pretzels and oh I mean I know
nothing if he even knows like how they
look he probably knows more than I do
oh just because you were brought up rich
enough to a well unlike me I had to put
dirt into the form of a pretzel I was
just guessing guy and it was delicious
that's too much flour oh thanks I
actually I actually needed that that's
that's plenty low okay did we clean this
table before I started working on no did
we dirty this table before we started
working on it yeah what was that did I
wash my hands before I started good cook
washes his hands I told you that in the
beginning wash not watch why are you
still over there why are you over
minding your
I think that helps I've seen people do
that it really liked it's the it gets
the east going they really like it they
like the smack yeah they're kinky little
[ __ ] like that yeah I'm really doing
this near over there laughing what are
you doing
I'm being patient it's not all about a
hard work sometimes we really don't have
enough time to at least
rise properly and have enough time and
that's alright what they don't know is
probably that's going to be the one item
that they really yeah that's a
nice-looking go buddy wait wait we're
missing an ingredient eggs
[Applause]
you think Jordan be freed soon with egg
[Music]
give me Salmonella
hers I think they were actually all
lacking with sugar I didn't see them use
any sugar whatsoever within their the
recipe I and anyway I think I've got
them beat my toe looks fabulous it's in
the fridge it's proving its gonna prove
itself worthy of being eaten by the most
critical critiques of the pretzel which
is not Ethan's invented inventor of the
pretzel yes sure
you know at the eggs for I know at the
eggs but that's great one seed my hand
was here but you're encroaching on my
third did I own this table he's got a
point you've done yet when I was
sweating are you making a volcano close
you close
[Laughter]
so we've proved it for an indeterminate
amount of time we've decided that it's
proved so we're gonna pull them out of
there proving locations in the middle of
us not recording and not recording Tyler
[Laughter]
oh yeah tell me
listen we did that for the pizza dough
dry so the general gist is that it
should double in size as yours doubled
Thanks now that that's oh yeah that's
doubled in size look on your ridges so
we need an oiled service a not a floured
do what you want no oils oiling me up
[Music]
yeah just
Oh Oh all right one more yeah you want
more than [ __ ] today Haley so we roll
them out and then we shape the pretzels
see mine double in size my freaking huge
huge look at that look at the size look
look at the shape it's a very nice
hello curve okay a little bit of a curve
but it's so nice I think this is
probably gonna be really close someone
just really good are we supposed to make
multiple pretzels yeah make like two
I got a thing boy I've got a pretzel I
did it I did it once one I [ __ ] did
it
Oh oh my god I got a pretzel oh my god
oh I'll never be able to recreate the
magic I recreated the magic make three
pretzels each one incrementally bigger
alright mine are ready to go in okay so
the important thing is when you have
your boiling water which is definitely
boiling you want what is in there okay
there's some particulates in there
alright so you put baking soda in the
water the recipes never say how much
it's always just some baking soda okay
so this water is not boiling but I don't
think that matters so I'm just gonna pop
her in I think it's supposed to float I
also think it's supposed to be boiling
just crisp in the bottom a little bit no
soggy bottoms here it's floating it's
floating it's floating oh that's good I
mean it's floating so that's a sign I'm
a guess that's good enough
oh my guess and then black that's my
first dumpling really what we're not
gonna have enough is for all of them on
this so that's why I was like too / yeah
I won't cook this one that's looking
okay it's still not boiling but okay I'm
gonna say this is good maybe okay those
are my two pretzels this one lost his
shape but that's what
okay see that look at that oil I should
have waited I'm gonna boil this big one
that's a nice-looking pretzel man I'm
gonna expect him to be that all right go
for it go go go what do I need to do
mine at the same time cuz we're out of
time
come on stuff it in no it's gonna be
ruined I'm I'm gonna have a handicap the
recipe says one at a time this is what
he even always does he's not a team
player he doesn't work for the crew he's
always you know looking for out for
himself
number one he never listens when you
know time is of the essence and he's
always taking his own time trying to
make things perfect
well even it's never going to be perfect
because you're not perfect okay you can
this guy is gonna be used for egg wash
to make sugar a crisp and browns around
the edge so I'm gonna make it an egg
yolk he got big big oh yeah mine didn't
puff I think because it wasn't boy get
out of the way you don't need two hands
for this one here we go yeah well maybe
absolutely dumplings what of it [ __ ]
yeah all right
so the ovens ready so we just pop them
right in nope we pop them right in no
that's [ __ ] gross man
called egg wash I know what it is
all right you don't even need a bowl to
get your egg wash cuz you just it comes
with a bowl scuse me excuse me
I don't need you excuse me excuse me
excuse me
oh oh oh gosh and I know the final step
I know it
watch out gonna cut it so it doesn't
slow dab snap snap okay they're going in
I think you should shut up all right 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9
I got it okay cut how long has it been
been 11 minutes this is what we looking
at right now oh all right the one up top
is looking real fun some of the bottom
fell off door that looks like a pretty
evenly baked pretzel I'm gonna get mine
just a little darker that smaller one
looks really good oh yeah that looks
like a real prison I feel like if
anything or add me down it'll be the
fact that I didn't put mine in boiling
water but that'll be proven by my big
boy if my big boy comes out big good you
know that it was my brother he they all
they all look pretty good
I do they do but now it's just gonna
come to the taste that's what I call
some places these are our pretzels they
are looking pretty good I'd say from an
aesthetic perspective
Tyler is definitely taking the cake on
this one those look great there's only a
little
even this year but like the shape the
consistency the the dough itself it
looks really nice
yours would be a second just because
they got the uniformity the twists
aren't you wait good I think the I think
that looks plump a little too plump ball
to pump mine look a mess I look like
super twisty well they don't look any
different than they did when I took them
out of the water because like just it's
soaking there I think it's shortened it
up a bit which is why it took a little
longer it's not quite as crisp as I yeah
but if history repeats itself the ugly
one may taste the best that's true it
might it might I also destroyed it with
salt because I didn't care you can see
just a stripe of salt here nothing
really consistent about this yeah you
did yours yours has a touch of quality
to it I will say it's a light lighter
salted site appeals to my heart mm-hmm
yeah but that's specific taste general
overall that's close to a true front
right quite a soggy
everything isn't looking great here
except for this so now it just looks
like a pig's nose that has a cold I
think this is the yolk that spilled over
and it got like sulfur eyes so that's no
good but the rest of it this is pretty
crisp and and it kind of nice the middle
might be a little raw but that's my mega
pretzel and also that got a better boil
but I can already tell it fluffed up
better because of the boil
anyway I'll put this over here that's
for dessert first glance of rippin and
open doesn't look good on the inside I
don't think that's done you know I'm
gonna give him a benefited out and go to
the more done look inside the dough
itself is salty which is surprising I
think yeah I think it was just like too
thick which is really a work well
there's also an odd aftertaste in it
mm-hmm
good that's good yeah a little wrong no
soggy bottom it's something about the
ingredients is off yeah if I got this
from the store I'd be like man they're
pretzels are off today but it's deleted
cuz I paid for yeah I didn't pay for no
no all right
it's definitely crispy on the bottom you
got a nice crisp there mm-hmm maybe to
Christmas whole bland I don't know what
it is but it's got a weird flavor least
mine does mmm I think I think what it is
too much water and flowers are really
diluted it it out and the bottom is
definitely hard
it's definitely sat down really baked
apart okay
no visually appealing this I'm looking
forward to this because it looks good it
looks cooked it's a bit tough but the
toughness isn't good that tastes exactly
like a pretzel it does that case that is
a pretzel honestly try the parts that
are twisted because those I think ended
up coming out at the exact right
consistency that's good
hopefully this is a good pretzel I've
got no flaws with that that's well done
it looks good the twist is good it's
very consistent the bake is good that's
good if it wasn't for this yeah the
crispy bomb I think was just because
maybe the pan we use was wrong because
we all have this that's a great pretzel
I mean what red actually I actually like
the crispy herb it's more this is good
that's really good I am pleasantly
surprised well done thank you I drank
mine the worst your second if it was
cooked better than me much better I'm in
that first place
actually I wonder if your fridge method
was better like because we proved ours
how we're supposed to be like even
though you didn't it's still like flaky
I'm honestly very surprised that we all
got something that looks like a pretzel
because none of us measure them all
right so this is a boiled version of
mine you don't want to go yeah it's
probably not cooked in the center i
would imagine and has an interesting
scent to it yeah that pretzel smell that
I smell that's gone now I think it was
just residual off from yours and now I'm
getting like that snot it just doesn't
feel appealing this is too much like
bread yeah I think I made bread Hey that
is Roetzel to recap Tyler if that was in
any store I would not question it in any
way that is a good pretzel yours was not
bad mine was just bad but that's because
I made bread instead and also put oil in
it I did a lot of things wrong in this
one but you know what you things would
have been better if you hadn't done it
yeah give him the time constraint that
we had though I think we did I think we
all did pretty good yes how long how
long is it supposed to set for or proof
for an hour we did like 15 but thank you
guys so much for joining me and if you
want to try pretzels at home it's not
that hard but follow what Tyler was
doing and not what we were doing or
follow a recipe no no no don't do that
that's actually stupid because its
stifles innovation and it stifles
critical thinking and it stifles
independence and you want like it's like
a parent you want to let your kids run
around in the woods like just do it let
him eat dirt let him eat worms that's
what I did as a kid that's what I did I
we turned out great of the three of us
the most well-developed of the three of
us are us too you can see that obviously
well developed yeah yeah yeah sure thing
okay yeah um but ya know if this is
great thank you everybody so much for
watching if you've got other ideas for
mix videos write them down in the
comments below we'll do a whole bunch
more in the future and check out Ethan's
channel at crank gameplays or at crank
game on youtube youtube.com slash
scraper game cranking plays and
twitch.tv slash Apocalypto underscore 12
over here thank you guys so much and as
always we'll see you in the next one bye
not that I'm surprised yeah I hate the
fact that Tyler beat me he never beats
me ever at anything and I kind of want
to kill myself just to get out of the
world where Tyler is better than me
[Music]
you
you